ein leiser tag der arbeit aber auch ohne
großkundgebungen fordern die
gewerkschaften in der korona krise
solidarität und schutz für arbeitnehmer
ein
der lange weg zurück wie cobit 19
patienten nach künstlicher beatmung
mühsam wieder lernen müssen selbst luft
zu holen
[Musik]
musik für mehr gemeinsamkeit die
berliner philharmoniker machen aus ihren
traditionellen europakonzert ein
besonderes
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem ersten mal nicht nur unternehmen
sondern auch menschen müssen vor dem
absturz geschützt werden
mit diesem appell ging der deutsche
gewerkschaftsbund in den tag der arbeit
weltweit ein tag des protests in zeiten
von corona ist aber eben auch der erste
mal ganz anders
so nämlich nicht mehr das sind bilder
vom letzten jahr
aber wie kann man solidarität fordern
und auch feiern ohne zusammenzukommen
wenn am brandenburger tor etwa kaum ein
mensch unterwegs ist die gewerkschaften
mussten improvisieren im netz und etwas
auch auf der straße henriette de
maizière berichtet solidarisch ist man
nicht alleine
das diesjährige motto des ersten mals
doch an diesem morgen sind es nur knapp
15 gewerkschafter die sich
stellvertretend am brandenburger tor
versammelt haben wir wollten den platz
halt nicht hergeben ist schon komisch
wenn man hierher kommt nach über 20
jahren das jedes jahr bin ich irgendwie
mit dabei und wenn man hierher kommt und
sieht dann auf der anfahrt das überhaupt
nichts los ist schmerz natürlich dass
die vielen kolleginnen und kollegen von
denen wir wissen dass sie gerade jetzt
dringend ihre gewerkschaft brauchen
nicht hier sein kann
die großveranstaltung des dgb zum ersten
mal heute per livestream im internet
musik reden appelle präsenz zeigen guten
sowie in schlechten zeiten für ein
in dieser schwierigen situation ist die
zentrale rolle der gewerkschaften
sicherzustellen dass die soziale
ungleichheit in dieser krise nicht noch
größer wird
das ist uns zum teil gelungen ich finde
es richtig dass das kurzarbeitergeld
angehoben wird den ersten mai zu den
menschen bringen auch ohne demo rainer
perschewski ist betriebsrat bei der
deutschen bahn
er fordert systemrelevanz braucht
tarifvertrag
wir haben wir der bahn zum beispiel auch
die bahn reinigung und die gehört auch
bei uns zu den ein schlechter bezahlten
beruf berufen
von daher wäre eine konkrete forderung
dass wir auch diese
dienstleistungsberufe die bisher so
nachrangig behandelt wurden auch künftig
besser betrachten und besser bezahlen
der erste mai in der krise und die
arbeit der gewerkschaften gefordert wie
selten
[Applaus]
in berlin ist am nachmittag ein
fernsehteam des zdf angegriffen worden
es hatte den kabarettisten abdel karim
bei einem dreh für die heute show
begleitet der war offenbar bereits
abgeschlossen als eine größere gruppe
junge erwachsene ohne vorwarnung auf das
team einprügelte mindestens fünf
menschen wurden verletzt meldet die
polizei sie nahm sechs tatverdächtige
fest abdel karim war vor ort blieb aber
unverletzt
seit jahren gehört er zum team der heute
show der programmdirektor des zdf
norbert himmler verurteilte den angriff
auf das team viele europäische länder
lockern mehr und mehr ihre corona
maßnahmen in österreich etwa gelten seit
heute praktisch keine ausgangs
beschränkungen mehr
auch deutschland geht einige wenn auch
sehr vorsichtige schritte spielplätze
dürfen wieder öffnen
gleiches gilt für zoos botanische gärten
sowie museen und ausstellungen und
gläubige dürfen wieder gottesdienste
feiern allerdings nur unter strengen
auflagen dominik müller rosell berichtet
abstand halten
sowohl vor als auch während des
gottesdienstes wo sonst tausend gläubige
in der basilika in kevelaer die
eröffnung der wallfahrt saison feiern
können es dieses jahr nicht mehr als 150
menschen seien um allen
sicherheitsregeln zu genügen in zeiten
von corona aber immerhin die kirchen
dürfen wieder mit leben gefüllt sein
nach sieben langen wochen die freude ist
groß und dennoch herrscht vorsicht und
verantwortungsbewusstsein bei den
menschen
da brauchen wir eine gute ausgewogenheit
jetzt weiterhin und wahrscheinlich auch
lange zeit die sehnsucht nach
gemeinschaft war und ist groß nach halt
und trost in schwierigen tagen
erleichterung heute in kevelaer
ich fand's schön dass jetzt endlich mal
wieder die möglichkeit war in der
basilika gemeinsamen gottes hin zu
feiern
dass die pforte eben offen ist als
zeichen es geht weiter es gibt ja auch
für alle die hier sind ein gutes gefühl
weil er eine gemeinschaft da ist und
genau das fehlt uns ja gerade und das
macht ja die zuversicht dass es schritt
für schritt immer besser werden die
geöffnete kirchenpforte das zeichen was
die marienwallfahrt und das geistliche
leben in diesem jahr wieder weiter gehen
können die hoffnung ist groß in kevelaer
dass es dabei bleibt und jetzt wieder
der blick auf die aktuellen corona
zahlen nach angaben der johns hopkins
universität gibt es einen leichten
rückgang bei den neuinfektionen 1500
menschen haben sich neu angesteckt seit
einer woche ist dieser wert täglich
unter 2000 geblieben
zur stunde sind mehr als 163 1000
infizierte durch tests bestätigt davon
gelten fast 127.000 betroffener als
genesen
6623 menschen sind in verbindung mit
cupid 19 gestorben
weitere interessante fakten zum corona
virus finden sie jederzeit online in der
zdf- heute- app zum beispiel wo steht
deutschland bei den infektionszahlen im
internationalen vergleich oder
wo haben sich hierzulande besonders
viele menschen angesteckt jeder mensch
reagiert anders auf das corona virus die
einen merken gar nicht wenn sie
infiziert sind oder haben nur leichte
symptome
andere kämpfen mit dem tod und müssen
über wochen künstlich beatmet werden
wie mühsam ist es danach zu lernen
wieder selbstständig luft zu holen
zeigen gabi h nett und torge bode georg
von schwarzenberg hat das schlimmste
hinter sich
drei wochen wurde der belgier hier in
der aachener uni- klinik künstlich
beatmet es ging ihm so schlecht dass er
gleich intubiert wurde
doch jetzt liegt er seit ein paar tagen
auf der entwöhnung station
hier lernt er wieder selber zu atmen ein
anstrengendes training in welchen
umständen hast du mehr nötig wenn ich in
anderen umständen hast du nötig und so
fruchtkörper sich wieder anzupassen
an die zeit der künstlichen beatmung
kann sich der 56 jährige nicht erinnern
er lag im künstlichen koma wie viele
andere corona patienten auch die
entwöhnung von der lungen maschine geht
nur schrittweise
weil die muskulatur der atmungsorgane
erst wieder aufgebaut werden muss dann
fangen wir an manchmal mit wenigen
minuten den patienten selbstständig
atmen zu lassen und nach kurzer zeit
erschöpft sich der patient braucht
wieder eine unterstützung und diese
phasen des selbst admins die den wir
langsam aus und so kommen wir dann
irgendwann an den punkt dass der patient
vollständig selber atmet georg von
schwarzenberg macht dank eines großen
expertenteams gute fortschritte
viel mehr personal noch als auf den
normalen stationen eine psychologin
einer ein sprecher heute selbst und den
schmuck ab zum beispiel wieder zu lernen
und sprechen zu lernen
wir haben ja doppelt so viel verraten
wahlen station um eben diesen wichtigen
schritt von der akuten erkrankung weg
von den ganzen maschinen wieder auf die
eigenen beine und wieder zurück ins
leben zu kommen
er hat es geschafft georg von
schwarzenberg kann schon wieder nahrung
zu sich nehmen
und er freut sich bereits auf die zeit
danach
ich muss mich wieder aufpäppeln soll
aber ich freue mich erste bier und immer
noch gibt es streit darüber wo das neue
corona virus genau herkommt us präsident
tom hat jetzt wieder china dafür
verantwortlich gemacht das virus stamme
aus einem labor in der chinesischen
stadt haan
damit widerspricht er seinen
geheimdiensten china selbst sagt das
virus sei in haan auf einem wildtier
markt vom tier auf den menschen
übergegangen
solche märkte sind mittlerweile verboten
stefan die schöne bauen berichtet wer in
peking auf den wochenmarkt geht der wird
viel frische ware finden mitunter
lebendig nah und zum anfassen wenn der
kunde denn mag
doch entgegen dem klischee werden in
peking wie im großteil chinas keine
hunde oder katzen zum verzehr angeboten
hunde und katzen essen das geht nicht
das sind haustiere
[Musik]
es gibt regionen da ist das eine
spezialität
das ist eine erst kultur dort wir hier
machen das nicht und doch sind in
manchen städten und provinzen chinas
hunde und katzen eine delikatesse
tierschützer beklagen seit langem den
handel verkauf und verzehr von
haustieren und wildtiere seitdem das
corona virus ingo hahn auf einem
tiermarkt ausgebrochen sein soll hat
china den verkauf von wildtieren
gänzlich verboten
die stadt shenzen geht noch weiter
exotische tiere und haustiere dürfen
nicht mehr verzehrt werden
zugelassen sind nur noch zehn tier
sorten wie rind schweine und geflügel
erfahrungen mit dem ebola virus und
anderen krankheitserregern dass der
verzehr von tieren ob haustiere oder
wildtiere die übertragungs chance von
tier auf mensch enorm steigert und
deswegen ist im sinne einer kontakt
unterbrechung oder kontakt minimierung
der verbot von verzehr ob haustür der
wildtier einleuchtend in rohan stehen
improvisierte verkaufsstände derweil
wieder dicht an dicht
da werden auch wieder frösche und
schildkröten verkauft um schön sein ist
das bereits verboten
in mehreren us-bundesstaaten wächst seit
tagen der widerstand gegen die korona
maßnahmen dabei ist der protest in
michigan jetzt fast aus dem ruder
gelaufen
die demonstranten drangen ins
parlamentsgebäude der hauptstadt lenzing
ein mehrere hundert und einige davon
bewaffnet im eingangsbereich forderten
sie ein ende der ausgangs beschränkungen
nur wenige tragen einen mundschutz
zuletzt hatte präsident trump aktionen
gegen den lockdown ausdrücklich
unterstützt
der demokratische bewerber um die
us-präsidentschaft joe biden hat den
vorwurf eines sexuellen übergriffes
zurückgewiesen
im us fernsehen äußerte er sich erstmals
öffentlich
es ist niemals niemals passiert so
beiden eine ex mitarbeiterin hatte
gesagt er habe sie 1993 sexuell
angegriffen
biden will im november bei der
präsidentschaftswahl gegen donald trump
antreten
zurück nach deutschland
es sei eine seltsame atmosphäre sagte
heute bundespräsident steinmeier in der
berliner philharmonie in diesem
wunderbaren bau wo sonst gäste aus aller
welt zusammenkommen so steinmeier ist es
mucksmäuschenstill
außer ihm war kein publikum da sondern
nur einige wenige der weltberühmten
philharmoniker um ihr europa konzert zu
spielen
corona bedingt eben ein bisschen anders
als sonst sebastian kowski
[Musik]
mahlers vierte mit sicherheitsabstand
und ohne publikum beim diesjährigen
europa konzert der berliner
philharmoniker dürfen nur 15 musiker
gleichzeitig auf der bühne sein
statt des sonst so opulenten 128
köpfigen orchesters corona zum trotz
betonte auch bundespräsident steinmeier
in seinem grußwort kunst und kultur die
wir gemeinsam erleben können das sind
keine verzichtbaren nebensachen das
erfahren wir gerade in diesen tagen
wieder neu
stärker als vielleicht sonst schätzen
wir das was wir vermissen
kunst und kultur sind eben in einem sehr
buchstäblichen sinn lebensmittel
eigentlich wollte heute chef dirigent
kirill petrenko die philharmoniker in
tel aviv zum klingen bringen im rahmen
eines staatsbesuchs des
bundespräsidenten vor großer kulisse
die hierbei vergangenen europa konzerten
in paris oder im norwegischen reeders
[Musik]
die philharmoniker stellen ihre gagen
der unicef nothilfe zur verfügung und
riefen auch die zuschauer zu spenden auf
für kinder auf der flucht und gleich
noch eine musikalische spendenaktion die
wir ihnen nicht vorenthalten wollen
queen hat we are the champions neu
aufgenommen für na klar die helden in
der korona krise
[Musik]
sehr schön das wetter anfang mai bleibt
er april ich zwischen main und donau
länger sonnig sonst sehr wechselhaft mit
teils kräftigen schauern örtlich auch
kurze gewitter
bei lebhaftem westwind 11 bis 16 grad
hier geht es gleich weiter mit helden
der hauptstadt berlin zwischen lockdown
und lockerungen einer reportage von
unserem kollegen carsten behrendt um 10
begrüßte dann christian sievers im heute
journal
danke sehr viel interesse wir wünschen
ihnen trotz allem ein schönes wochenende
und sind morgen wieder da wenn sie mögen
auch wieder sehen